it seemed like a lot of the stories were
an issue of class that that in terms of
like not being able to afford proper
legal representation i mean i know you
had one gentleman that made six figures
a year
that that was still fighting and he had
that t-shirt that was like this you know
message to the judge and how he felt he
was being discriminated against but it
seemed like a lot of people it was
really an issue of not having
the money and also not having access to
the legal right
that was a big factor like because we we
were trying to get
all of those dynamics i guess you know
it was like the little guy that couldn't
afford it and it seemed that
they were in the court the longest and
someone with money
it was kind of the same thing but in a
different light they never had to go to
court every day and miss three days of
work because their attorneys would show
up you know but the guy who takes three
days of work now is behind
another thousand bucks because he can't
afford the next
check you know right and so
we had
as much as we could we did a piece on
alec baldwin in his case and
he was in the first film and then there
was a decision to you know the
celebrities that go through divorce and
you know they can afford i think they
feel that they can afford that but at
the end of the day it's like they still
couldn't see their children that was
that was the factor
that i heard and even in alec baldwin's
voice that you know you you can i loved
what he said when i met him in atlanta
that you know if you if someone told you
your kid was on the other side of that
brick wall and all you had were your
teeth to get through it you're gonna
start chewing and that was true you know
the kids are
are just
innocent and it feel it felt at the time
of filming and
maybe things have changed today but it
also it always felt like the kids had a
bounty over their heads and we heard
that from
um people groups that were
at this for like 15 20 years and said
we've been trying to do this for a long
time what you guys are doing and so it
was like a motivational thing for us to
keep going